gilad is back on the show
we're just talking about
the difference very subtle difference
between
deepening the death into emptiness and
love versus the
self finding
another
little ground
to
stand on and proliferate itself
we decided to start recording
very subtle distinction
requires a high level of discernment
yes
and another and in another sense it's
pretty simple
and it can boil down to the
just feeling or isolating or distilling
the
[Music]
the pure resonance the pure joy
that
is this like as an underlying underlying
reality
and let it lead the way and then in this
joy
there is
hardly divisions it's
like maybe little wobbles to none you
know once you're in this like
a clarity of joy
and
kind of like a heart
expensive
energy once you tune into it a bit maybe
through a little bit of imagination
and
yeah just this inner
in a pool
which can be also
a pool
so then it's it's just there
right then it's just the courage to
listen to it right to like to
in a sense what you pointed out to
sacrifice
the
some perceived
uh benefits or
attachments to other
scenarios or trajectories
that seem
like
another choice in that point
yeah there's endless ways to um
to
not die into space
and endless reasons
[Music]
take your
pick your excuse
right
yeah
yeah there's so many grounds to stand on
one of the one of the easiest ways to sh
for me to share
what it feels like is that it feels like
a
a new way to proliferate a sense of
identity that's not space
so you mean
like that identity which is not space
right
so
any
it's like
it's like
going
in
to more and more subtle
grounds
for a sense of self to proliferate
itself
until that ground of the sense of self
to proliferate itself
is
completely seen to be
illusory
yeah
nice yeah
yeah that's actually
a critical point and
i've been
amplifying the observation recently for
that exactly for that
deeper layers of the self
so if we
we know we have some experience some
access to that
to the reality of everything is
self being self everything is
one everything is
so
it's easy often
and it's kind of a trap and i observed
it in me to
hide behind this non-dual self
behind the non-dual
uh
realization which takes a shape which is
a kind of a frequency
and then it kind of
hides the the still the the the
proliferations right proliferations the
the the bubbles the specs of solidity
which
doesn't allow them to be seen and
accepted
and thus dissolved
so then yes so then it's it's subtle
because it's not about anything as a
thing but it's about what projects like
the self which is right kind of like in
relationship with the thing
right right it's most of
yeah it's like
the
sense of
self in relation to the sense of being
the creator
is like one of the most subtle um
layers
because it's just a sensation
it's yeah
yeah
and once you enter
to like
a kind of like a doorway like that
then what can happen is suddenly what
opens up is an
is a new domain of energetic
exploration which like
kind of expands into a
more
noticeable or a
[Music]
tangible experience sensation to like
penetrate to
and then you can actually see hey there
is a layer here there is a
there there's a self in a sense it's
it's subtle
right but
this it's something it's something which
kind of like
you can say around the shows
in different ways
right and then the other way to look at
it is the from
spaciousness to
any sense of
creator or
capitalist self or god or absolute or
whatever
that there's another story
on that end as well so you can look at
it from the lowercase s self
to creator but you can also look at it
from the sense of emptiness to creator
so you can look at it from both those
ways that how does that arise how does
my new sense of identity as god arise
and then how do i proliferate
a further sense of self through that
identification with god and typically
that shows up as
i know answers
listen to me
um
now it's time for me to share
uh um
and
if you if that's seen through which
usually takes uh more
stillness
more silence more doing nothing
more relaxation
more just bathing in perfection
then
it can express from emptiness from
spaciousness itself instead of from a
new identification as god
yes
or you can say we from a position which
which still
is
kind of hiding or is in need for
to gain something from
yes
object
or right
because i'll still get something from
all of my
other
because i'm still projecting a sense of
others
projecting a sense of lack that i can
still get something to feel more whole
yes
and what's important to say that that
in itself is absolutely fine absolutely
not sure there's nothing wrong with that
so that's exactly another thing to
actually see
as a creation
and to
[Music]
and to kind of like take a step back
reverse
the your
your steps from from this
yes my conscious creation
projection
to the self which
is conjuring it up
so even that like
a natural sense of like still projecting
something and proliferating and and
hiding behind
a construct
is in itself something to
like kind of locate it's it's a it's
subtle source it's causal source as a
sensation as a self
and
and accept it
even though the thing itself but the
the existence of the thing the the self
which is like under the thing and when i
say self again i mean
the great self the great uh
universal mind
and you mentioned before so the
lowercase self you want to um
maybe uh
elaborate a bit more in case someone
doesn't fully
understand the
term
yeah so we made it when we make a
distinction like there is
the big self
the capital itself and the small self
yeah so in that sense
a small self would be
uh
pretty much
any sense of identity that is not
emptiness
and so
that in its grossest or most solid form
shows up as
i am my name and my body and you are
your name and your body
and we are all separate
and
i am not whole and therefore i will
go and get wholeness through
achievements
things like that
um and then in its more subtle
forms
that are less solid
the lowercase sense of self can show up
like a spiritual ego
like oh i now know oneness and so now
because of that i can begin sharing
that what i know
endlessly through
all different types of content
and
listen to me because i know the truth
more than you do
and
that
is
a more
uh subtle
it's so much more subtle
it's so much more subtle and it's it's
rarely is really rarely seen through
i could almost sense
that i had spent
lifetimes
in that
consciousness
i'd spent lifetimes
being a spiritual teacher from a
spiritual ego
and that
the space that's empty before the
spiritual ego before the spiritual
teacher
is only now finally being seen
and
being
lived as true non-existence true
non-beingness
um
so yeah so those are some of the subtle
subtle
uh
subtle
spectrum from complete illusion in a
sense of self versus complete emptiness
yeah
more changes for you
like just on a
on the level of your of your life of
your daily
[Music]
energetic mental
uh
navigation
true peace
true perfection
like the creator sense of self
wants to
[Music]
proliferate itself by
sharing with itself
what truth is
and the empty spacious
no-self
is
absolute perfection period as it is
totally still
um
so
yeah peace and happiness true peace and
happiness indescribable peace and
happiness not the artificial
um
happiness that's accrued from
material possessions or relationships or
substances and not the
uh artificial happiness from
floating on
i am the godhead um
addiction
[Laughter]
yeah what about you what's changed
what's changed for you
so it is in process but yeah what you
refer to here it's a great understanding
that actually recently i've been also
coming back to and also in the last few
days
and and seeing the the immense
freedom and power and wisdom in this
approach and it's kind of a wisdom which
is beyond the wisdom of the
of the yogi you know of discrimination
you can still apply this this of course
it's there's no
it's beneficial but it's the wisdom of
knowing that
this freedom this uh perfection this
peace
this
reality or
self
doesn't need
anything anyone any experience or not
experience to be what it is
it's there is no attainment
or loss there there is no
anything
which cannot
which can make it not what it is already
which can undo it which can which can
give it to you to any to any
uh human mind
to any
like a scarlet ants that says it to any
phantom
and then the quest is actually the
proliferation of the phantom
right of the of that mind of that
one who thinks it is attainable that
it's up to him to make this
happen
so then i love also how we describe how
he defines compassion compassion is is
just not projecting yourself into
anything right
simple so simple
right
compassion is emptiness of self
yes be and in a sense you can say also
being as you are it's this totally total
embrace
of as you are of as
right any condition any condition which
comes about
spontaneously
it's just like that it's the
dissociation of
i am
here somewhere
because
i emerge somehow into this life
out of out of the blue
and then every day i go to sleep and
everyone goes to sleep and again emerges
somewhere from from a total
darkness
emerge again
so that's that's a great analogy
actually like this right yeah that's
that's a technology yes just happened so
what wakes up there this is
right
lightweight nice so basically can you
keep the sense of darkness throughout
the day
yes that's
within the light within just a pure
experience of
right light of life itself right can you
be in a superposition of darkness and
light
yes and when you say darkness
let's uh let's also be a bit more
accurate
which is what you shared when you
reference sleeping in essence yes so
it's the
absence
of um
this kind of darkness is the apt is the
absence
of
basically i would say that
maybe it's to put it simply which cares
or what she cares yeah it's kind of a
carelessness it's kind of like a
a love which is
which is
dot which is called in a sense just like
right whatever
like an okayness like an innocence
yeah
yeah
yeah and then
and then all all of this uh
you know [ __ ] up-ness
or
what we call proliferation of sev the
hijacking the
small cell of this all
clouds and layers of identity
can be seen just likely
is
is just
expression is just like one side of the
coin
and somehow
when we see them as they are like in
this light in this like
uh
understanding is acceptance
what naturally takes the place i feel
for most people actually is this
more
in the relative sense the more wise uh
manifestation of mind
the most the more peaceful the more wise
the more loving also the more
spontaneous
right the more following
the true
joy and resonance
without
trying to secure something to gain
something
everybody wants this like distorted
innocence like the cha everybody wants
actually to be like the child to
yeah to play like like like a child
that's like it's
maybe the ultimate
attainment you know
yeah
which is
in many ways where
the
collective
is
heading
which is like seeing through the
matrix
stronghold and
recognizing that true
play true love true abundance prosperity
for all is
no no-brainer
and so
why not have that be the
baseline
um moving forward for all generations to
come so
yeah
i like the lighthouse analogy just
be a lighthouse in your
apartment in your neighborhood in your
workplace in your wherever you are
just setting the intention
to be this
without without any significance but
just
this simple intention to
to elevate
the above the clouds
of
insanity
complexity
the
the nonsense of adults
on this
most adults on this planet
and
and you know like the it's like that
there is there are many holes in in this
in this net it's like in this web
that
anyone has
ability to just sit through and then
counter just pick your pick the whole
pick the
like in this net it's it's not like
totally sealed
there's always
in a sense a way out of a certain state
of mind
certain a momentum of identity
we have one of the clear differences
um
between
emptiness and
the sense of
creator
is
that there's a
an indescribable
finality or end of seeking with
emptiness
that was not present
prior
yes as though the self was still seeking
its death
because it was still
intertwined with the sense of being
creator
yes that peace and that happiness
that we're
referencing
that
only truly comes from an end of seeking
because even in
doing absolutely nothing
one can feel
completely perfect and whole
which before that was not felt
even while doing nothing the sense of i
must do something
was still very subtly present like a
like a humming in the background
i must do something
to be valid to be whole
and then that
ends
and then
it's really important to not go back to
doing
it's really important to sit in that
space
sit in the space
to sit in emptiness to be empty
to see every single proliferation of
self that arises
every proliferation of story that arises
every single one see through it see
through it keep seeing through it
let those little karmic seeds dissolve
vanish more and more into space
and
then and only then can you actually
re-emerge as being totally vanished yet
the lighthouse
because you have no sense of self
and you don't care there's a
carelessness like you said
yes
and paradoxically
to what i said uh
earlier
it's by the
understanding that there is no way out
right
so nothing can actually
stop this it's
the will goes on for eternity and
the only way out is this understanding
there is no way out
and this the train cannot stop i can
stop
or at least slow down
and
look
and investigate and
dissolve
accept
and it doesn't mean not to follow in the
meantime uh if it's naturally arising
your your joys
your
just
natural inclinations preferences desires
so yeah we're not
uh suggesting suppression also
i assume for you too yeah right
we're not it's not a suppression kind of
thing
it's finding the sweet spots it's
finding the this natural ripeness
maturity
some call it wisdom
understand like the there is no true
gain in anything which is of this world
it's not true game
it's so it's for it's for fun it's like
for joy but it's not for
anything else
essentially essentially in the deepest
in the deepest
sense right
excuse me
another
good one
has been
if you
fear death just wait until you figure
out that you're infinite
i throw it back my friend
what are you doing
playing playing it like
pretending like there is hope
oh man hope it's the
it's kind of a poison yeah
yeah
through
there
through the eternal
uh endlessness
there's an
ability to
cease proliferation
and
that
superposition between
uh total
uh stillness and total
absolute insane movement of all sorts
is
so cool
yeah
it's like what comes up is just what's
left is to rejoice
rejoice
right
right which is identical to the child
that's playing in the grass under the
sun right now
so
so be the children that are
have their basic needs met and that are
just able to
be joy itself
um
let's play let's play
yeah yeah that's actually
that's great and and i feel like for
many
uh
many folks many could say seekers in
these times
which dive into the
non-dual teachings and teachers and
all of that
yeah all of that
realm
i feel that often what's kind of like
missing is actually the
[Music]
the integration of the into the life
force or the life force itself
like kind of the unleashing of of the
life force
which truly enables
one to go beyond the mind and to and to
integrate this realization
deeper and more viscerally
and then also giving you actually the
true ground for practicing the the
dissolution the emptiness not from the
mental or even the stillness kind of
meditation
but it gives you like
kind of work or
a mirror effect to see what's actually
you have to still deserve so actually
it's super important
and that's actually the fastest track to
to fall if to to fully follow the life
force
while maintaining this wisdom
uh remembrance
and application in a sense of
i am nowhere here i'm nowhere to be
found i am
none of it
yeah
yeah it shows up in such
like
[Music]
like ways you know and like to
[Laughter]
you know like breathe through that move
through that be a little little like
reptile or chimp or a little a baby
that
also and then thou
d
you
right and then that's another way for
the feeling of emptiness to be rooted
joy
love to express itself
because the little prison
that's up here
has been
broken over and over and over and over
and over and over and over no more
conditions
we
we live in a
a very modern
time and something that's not
really
talked about enough
is the internet
and how
the internet for the vast majority of it
is
the proliferation of census of self and
stories
and
identities
and the cell phone itself and all the
messaging apps and all the social apps
and accessing that daily
is just the bathing in
senses of self senses of identity senses
of stories narratives self-images
self-esteems self-worth
lack beliefs all of that
and so the only way
to
really
vanish
repeatedly into emptiness
is
many ways to
just stop
using those devices and those messaging
apps and the social apps and talking to
people
incensively all the time
monks go to caves
in the mountains for years
and have been for millennia because of
that
because they want to know
emptiness they want to know space they
want to know no self they don't want to
proliferate a sense of self that's then
engaging with other senses of self
around their identities and lacks and
stories and all this type of stuff
so
then and only then you can
re-engage let's say with
the messaging apps and the social medias
and the conversations and all that stuff
but it does take a
in many ways it takes a a discipline an
indescribable discipline um yeah
diet
in a sense
and then burning desire also
towards that
clarity that
it's helpful it's serving it's uh
enabling this uh
upper focus this
yeah
one point of discipline and in some
cases
if if your desire is true it's really
truly
very intense like for example a frank
yang
yeah then then in a sense
you'll do what's necessary in the midst
of whatever you do or don't do
um
but yeah it's great to take times of
total
fast fasting from from this
occupation and interactions and people
and dynamics and screens
yeah to more simplicity
silence
contemplation
because
in a sense it's like
when the wall is thick when when the
layer is is is when there is an
accumulation of
of this
identity that is being carried for many
years
usually it takes like kind of a special
mission special op
to
get like the the air out of it out of it
like
yeah and if i drain the swamp
so it can be very helpful to
dedicate
some time
yeah
some good time to
to death
right
right yeah imagine
uh
two decades of
proliferation
and then
um trying to
uh
to see through all of the different
facets or dynamics of that proliferation
without uh making it a full-time job
you can't you won't finish this lifetime
you won't you will not
there's no chance you will if you don't
make it a full-time job if you don't
make
uh the dissolving of the sense of self a
full-time job
you will not finish this lifetime
yet at the same time there is none even
in the first place it's just a complete
assumption
right but then as long as you have the
experience of
suffering of
i am projected here in this
reality
somewhere
whether it's the body or more subtle
layers
and
yeah so it still generates pain
it still generates suffering it still
generates
right the experience of there is
something to lose even if i am in the
gut state in the awareness state they
still the fear of losing it is still
the suffering basically because i think
i am still somewhere
right
yeah so then
it's like it's an endless rat race
in a sense
so then
so so yeah my the point was the point is
that
if still there is that experience and
the desire to
so to speak
see fully
the
the reality of this state of the
statements like it's already attained
freedom
is ever the case
it doesn't need you or me or anything to
be what it is
so it takes a great deal of
burning desire
the
highest prioritization
fire of truth and following your heart
whatever it takes you
the the
many ways and i like also about carl
ranza
he's really great source for that kind
of
understandings he says like
you can only fail
you can only fail
and once you once you become like an
absolute failure that's where you
succeed so to speak
you have to become an absolute failure
you can only fail you know
once all
efforts are exhausted
by by grace by accident by by
whatever it's it can like
come so to speak it can it can like
consume the the
the human
mind uh
and
and kind of take over uh with this
natural spontaneity and we all know this
we all know this experience
but it's not permanent it's not logged
in it's not
uh
a consistent reality devoid of suffering
the void of
conflicting
right
of any
conceptualization or differentiation
completely devoid of location completely
right all of those things
um
yeah just the cessation of projection
period
yeah and then all playgrounds become
equally
uh
fun
there's
there's nothing which is not the
playground
the only ultimate playground is all
equally
right
that
right right so
another way to say is
upon
like realization of cessation of
projection there is only projection
which is all equal
and all
also
appearing different
which is beauty itself
that's why the middle way is so
important or
the um
like
yeah i mean you can't you can't even you
can't even talk about it um because any
time you talk about it it automatically
makes it partial
so
you you have this you have to when you
do try and speak it you have to speak it
as holistically as possible
um
which includes
the illusion of the parts
and so
it's crazy to even try and talk about it
yes and yeah the illusion of the parts
and where you actually see through
experientially
this illusion is is on the subtle
layers of sensations of
causal
self
arising right
that's like the kind of like the bed
rock the
right
the the fabric is is kind of like
resting there and
appearing as
all kinds of
separate parts which then we call
illusory whatever separate blabla
expressions and
dualities
yeah i feel it's a key and i'm curious
if if you've been
yeah
because i noticed also we haven't spoke
we haven't spoken for a while and not
just like this changing your energy and
and expression and yeah like a shift
which is which feels really good
so i'm curious if you've been uh
actually engaged in this kind of uh
practice or
just it's not even a practice it's more
like
a wisdom maybe a natural byproduct of
wisdom which is just to situate to
to go deeper and
accept slash dissolve slash
understand
yeah
is it is that is it something you've
been
playing
yeah i would say
uh in a very like natural and
organic way in the last couple of months
um
these like
last really subtle
um
expressions of the projection of a sense
of self has diminished
and
the
um
the sense of being totally devoid of
identity
and
spacious empty and love
um
has emerged in an unprecedented way in a
way that has never been present before
and
um
i
i i deeply i deeply not only like i do
credit that actually to this
um
this
like
insane um
desire for emptiness above everything
else
um
but i also
um
i credit it to
um the respite
so like the ability to retreat
from
the proliferation of
world and story and self and others
all of that
to retreat from that
um
so that you can more clearly see like
what you were describing that bedrock of
causal seeds of the sense of self and
others and world arise and express
and
to
then be like [ __ ] whoa that was crazy
that conglomerated not of craziness how
it projected itself and then went off
and
and then
but this
is
love itself before that
crazy illusion illusory projection and
um
and so i
uh yeah that i would say has been yeah
the last the last couple of months but
like really like now is
feels so good and and i really feel like
it's it's in many ways like a training
uh it's like training wheels also
because
the thing about
saying that you're done
um
is that
there's uh
there's like
there's only impermanence
um and so there's only more
uh quote work to do at the same time
that you are feeling the absolute
perfection when you do totally nothing
so
meaning when the space goes out when
love goes out and engages with itself in
all worldly dynamics
those more and more subtle senses of
self will arise and be seen through and
purified ongoingly
so
yeah to say that one is completely empty
of all
karma is a very
um
it's impossible it's also very bold um
and it takes a lot of
um
yeah it takes a lot of uh whatever this
is
and
yeah man what about you
how have you been like the last couple
of months with with this because you
also
do feel different
so
[Music]
so what i
what i saw what i noticed
what i experienced also is a spectrum
of
let's call it versions of myself
and of choices
and frequencies
and the spectrum
went from like
joy and bliss and
simple
radiance
to
kind of dark and heavy and lethargic
and almost depressive sense like there
was a little wave of like something
in the flavor of like
kind of a realistic
heavy uh
couple of weeks
[Music]
so
i've been taking all of that as
one is as a
as something which actually like
understand that it has to play out
it has to play out one for me to see
something for this like localized
conscious
consciousness to see something and also
to deepen
what we've been talking about is
conviction this
sense of uh impermanence the sense of
nothing sticks the sense of
amplifying the this um
strengthening
the the thirst for wisdom for true
wisdom
kind of like this point of no return and
for me
i had i had already this point of no
return and i had it
i had it
yeah quite quite a lot of times i would
say even
but i still feel
there are more to come kind of like
points of knowing 10 for me
and
i persist basically i i've persisted
with a
with deepening this vision
the knowledge
that
i'm all of it
and when i say i it's like this
mysterious and
in a sense unexplained doesn't come from
anywhere existence
which wakes up in the morning and it's
all of it
sometimes it thinks it's it's like it's
something there's like
some kind of
picture of a frame in the movie hijacks
another
right
as our friend says so
so that's been great just to see it just
to see it play out
and
in
moving and in that sense
i feel
uh
it's like
bringing me back to what we've been
discussing like the the desire to
actually go back to even more simplicity
more like natural rhythm of joy
and a
dissolution basically yes
right yes
remembering this is
this is the only way in a sense to be
to be
in the state of love of compassion is to
be totally out
of the game yeah
so
that's that's
that's still
my very like
top desire i would say in a sense
but still i've been seeing like also
other desires which uh
allegedly contradicted it's still the
same desire
but just coming from it more like a
local
unwise
layers of self
so then also accepting that
loving that seeing that as it is
and understanding it's only it's only
pointing me to a pure state of being a
pure sense of self which all it wants is
is the joy of of being of expressing
of playing
of being free of the weight
of the world
right in a sense and then everything is
can be let in naturally naturally
everything is attracted everything comes
into place everything brilliantly
intelligently
plays out catered
given
supporting this
vehicle this body this uh
creature identity
yeah so that's that's more like on the
periphery
right while having this crystal clear
established understanding
and attitude
of
knowing all of that still is the stream
of death
in a sense it's already it's already too
late whatever is happening here
it's too late
nothing can
alter or change or attain
this absolute perfection freedom peace
because anything that happens it's too
late it's already gone
in the realm of experiences so that's
the paradox
and
phil that's that's for me what i i
investigate and
and deepen in in the last two years and
continue doing that yeah
it's so joyful so once you like just
combine this and
like being in the source of the paradox
of hispanics
it's indescribable joy it's just
you can't stop love
it's a joke yeah
right
such a joke
totes
yeah another fun way to visualize it
that's come up is
to
like
imagine just like going taking your
hands and like going and carving out
through your eyes into your brain and
taking your entire brain and just
throwing it outside of your body
and then just feeling how there's just
space inside of your cranium and then
like that is like another way to just
like feel
um
i get identity-less
um
without agency without doership
without manipulating whatever is
carefree playful
not caring
whatever
whatever
uh
and yet at the same time like
you know present with that empty love
to whatever is
for it to heal
because it's you
so
um
yeah man
that's a natural for me for most of us
the natural is like this current of
evolutionary realignment
which just
takes place by by this very
act and surrender of
taking a step back observing
yeah
and all of that
it's great we
yeah while we do this work also we
[Music]
we become we become truly also available
to our
to our brilliance
to our most
natural and
abundant and epic right
right
game character
right
yeah
got the
yeah the power that's felt from feeling
perfect
while also
the
the game shape-shifting
to
realize its perfection um
it's just you can't find anything like
that in anything that the self can
proliferate and
at all you just can't like
you get glimpses of it when you're when
you've lost your sense of self while
you're in the middle of sex or while
you're in the middle of a a peak um
meditative absorption or in the
um
psychedelic or anthogenic experience uh
you know you get glimpses of it and then
you
[Music]
congeal again a little sense of self
that's a little less uh
nodded
but
to feel the unknottedness
of perception ongoingly
is
it's so gold man it's so
gorgeous yeah
it just ever is
in a sense and it's not anything
so it's so it's in a sense it's subtle
but also it's not because it's so
obvious
in another way
it's so obvious
it's so hilarious it's so hilarious
[Music]
and it's not the thing my friends
that's the most important i would say to
my message
it's not a thing it's not an experience
it's not
anything
it's not
all
anything
how can it be
great
beautiful
amen
it's a
a new little yoga you develop
bro
this [ __ ] just expresses itself in
however the [ __ ] it wants
and it just works
it just works man
it takes that little
it takes that little uh knot
and immediately unnots it
nice
nice a knotted like little like
it's just like breaking whatever script
is
like
running
oh yeah
it's
it's very reptilian i really don't know
how else to put it it's like if you
merge it's like if you merged a reptile
like a like an alligator with a frog
with like a lion or
with like a bird
like all of that [ __ ] like just merge
all of that together into
like this which is a product of the
evolution of it yeah
yeah so we're just relating in the brain
also it's part of the brain it's part
even of the human brain you know we have
the reptilian brain
it is in a sense more close to
not really but like chronologically
wise to source
to the beginning
than this uh suit
so yeah i like it it's like it's all
it's gonna just play with these all of
these energies and and be there
yes whatever be whatever how can one how
can one be an energy master or a jedi
if they haven't mastered all of the
energetic
uh principles of all of those reptilian
weird
style of expressions including that
innocent child that
just
doesn't know anything the total
unknowing unknowing completely
yeah
yeah
that's the number one
i guess uh
kind of like weight or limitation is is
us being uh as i mean as humans being
knowledgeable
yeah
thinking we know
thinking we know anything we know
anything
it's like
where does it lead why does it hit us
so it's right just disrupting the
knowledge [ __ ] knowledge
[ __ ] knowledge
let's end let's end
let's end together
all knowledge
right and there is knowledge in terms of
assembling a tesla
there's knowledge
yeah and con conversing and whatever
just
but it's but it is it's not you can say
if you if you look at it it's not
doesn't take actually knowledge
in its naturalness it's just it's it's
the same as waking up in the morning you
don't need knowledge to wake up there
you go it just happens right right
what's waking up again what's
waking you up
so it's also paradoxical because
what what
what think it knows
it's another like natural also
spontaneous
arising
right so it's not even like changing
anything within
this dream of of the one who knows it's
more like
disrupting it as you say right
yeah
ha what thinks it knows
so good
yeah man
all right good stuff
who
are you
[Music]
we have so many infinite bras out there
huh
ah
who are you
now infinite bras
show up
wherever you are
i gotta say
vanishing is [ __ ] sweet
it's
it's in many ways more sweet than
showing up
so um
so and then you do both at the same time
and it's the end but it's uh
the endless end but
yeah man it's just it's wayne it's way
nice to just be nobody and be nothing
and be nowhere
um
and then be everywhere and everybody and
everything but
but that that itself is just that's
healing that is healing
being nobody
is healing
i like it
i like it it's actually it's also
powerful it's also
pretty powerful and this
i actually don't want you to show up
until you're nobody
[Laughter]
yeah you know what i said like the
influence
right yes
so
yeah
yeah and and again it's like a fit for
me
it's not necessarily like a binary i
mean it's it also can be
but
i had this uh very powerful uh
phases where i actually
saw like this the nobodiness and still
everything goes on
brilliantly lovingly perfectly
with the triggers with whatever comes up
and what would describe it maybe the
best in like human terms is is a magic
is a state of it's total matter magical
flow right
and then it and then it feels like you
are like kind of like an empty
like almost like a wormhole
and everyone that looks at you interacts
with you
is
he's just seeing himself
and he and he knows it and then you see
also for the person he recognizes on
some deep level that
that's what happens so it's like this
empty love empty love
so
yeah
so definitely this this
it can be glimpsed it can be experienced
it can be kind of
brought up
or just
step step down you know the nowhere
into the state
but then for me like
it wasn't permanent
so
so the mind or like the one who still
needs something came back
which is fine which is fine too it's all
it's all good it's so like in the same
time i can i can i can see i can like
put him down to sleep any moment right
yet
it's so easy to get caught in the things
that don't
allow one to
permanently be devoid of self identity
location
all that
to be like what you said a empty love
reflection
everywhere
um
yeah it's just it's so easy to get
tied back into that and so
it's
you know just
over and over and over and over over and
over and over and over and over
but the good news
that
nothing sticks nothing ever sticks
so
every
illusory moment
is another empty
opportunity
to see that i'm i'm nowhere to be found
i keep exhausting this this
momentum of of projecting myself and
choose com in a sense it looks like
choosing compassion
somehow
i like it i like it
yeah and another way to feel it is like
a one beingness that's
present
yeah exactly like everything is the same
thing
the same being the same eye the same
eyes
yes
same nano particle
or a
micro quantum
entity
dancing in the wind
very good
yeah we had
we had uh
we had mentioned this
in the
months that we were together um
and
it's cool to see it finally
come is this
this dialogue but from
what is now just feels it feels great
and uh
yeah
so
yeah
it's very good
it's very good my friend very good very
good one
very good
yeah so we'll see how this keeps playing
out uh i mentioned to gilad that
somebody commented on one of our
previous conversations and said
something like does gilad have his own
youtube channel yet
and so
we'll see how that comes to
life
absolutely
we will
nice nice yeah glad uh we were able to
have another pow wow so we have a what
do we have we have a couple other
previous episodes together you can just
look up uh gilad on simulation you can
find those episodes
yeah some previous versions
right
whatsapps and
right
uh
yeah and then there's other stuff in the
bio that you can find probably gillard's
instagram
and yeah would be updated also
soon
but yeah my instagram and soon other
gateways
nice
we'll interact
and as you guys know
thank you for tuning in we love you
we love you we love you observing on
the wave of joy and
compassion
compassionate emptiness
amen
good stuff
yeah
hit the
subscribe button if you haven't yet like
the video if you haven't yet also helps
the algo leave a comment with your
feels on the episode
and share it with people if you feel
like it resonated or could help
those that are
seeking
that is all
folks infinite love from the infinite
bras
i don't know
i don't know